yeah yes there was yeah um so you
returned home to do this film right or
nearby yeah Oh in the same neighborhood
that we were born into I mean by house
we shot and was literally a few blocks
away from the house that we were born
into and that that the main reason we
did that is we believe in like the
summer camp model of filmmaking where
everyone goes away and we live and
breathe this thing for you know in the
case of our independent films is really
only a matter of like three or four
weeks so that's something that we love
and in general just the support of
nature of being in an environment that
is excited about a film coming there and
being shot as opposed to LA where you're
kind of like a thorn and someone's side
when you show up with with you know a
camera so a thorn that they hope to make
a lot of money on the forms that they
will ya that they will charge you 20
thousand dollars to pull out I'm gonna
rape that thing yes exactly get so so
yeah but you know our parents live there
we slept our parents house a lot of our
crew slept at our parents house you know
we we slept in the house that we shot in
and you know yeah you know use one of
our friends houses there and you know so
it's all about you know by any means
necessary like what Mark was talking
about the economy of scale of well okay
well you know this is kind of a big film
that we're trying to make independently
so we need to work every angle to our
advantage and make it as comfortable and
as cheap as possible so when you went
back to their to shoot what type of sort
of epiphanies did you have because I'm
sure growing up were in high school you
had your own ideas of what success would
look like as a 37 year old and then
you're coming back there was a scary was
it exhilarating
no it's pretty great coming to New
Orleans because it's just a huge support
system I mean our parents and their you
know their to help cook meals for us and
Steve's this is our lead actors mom was
the head caterer on the movie because
she used to run this fantastic Greek
restaurant and you know we were shooting
in the arcade where Jay and I used to
play you know air hockey against each
other 20 years earlier you know so it
feels much more like a welcoming and a
homecoming and I didn't personally have
any trepidation about going back to that
that just felt like we need the support
to make you know what is essentially the
DNA of a huge budget sports comedy on a
micro-budget scale and and I like the
combination of those two elements I
think that's what makes the movie
special but you know we needed a special
support system to pull it off
you